bene bisogna che prima o poi se vogliamo
prato questo sentiamo play si chiama
scappa dal 100 piedi ed è un nuovissimo
gioco pauroso vediamo che succede ci
sono delle impronte ok
questo è importante cosa che stiano le
impronte dei
100 piedi sono le impronte 200 piedi
e sul soffitto e creduti si vita
purtroppo finito in un'altra stanza è un
altro gioco
praticamente e non c'è tempo non c'è
molto tempo per spi che remo ha visto
che velocissimamente anche stanno
eliminando una volta eliminando i
personaggi in una volta quindi chi
capita 100 piedi deve eliminare gli
altri personaggi invece che un
personaggio normale deve trovare le
chiavi e aprire le porte guai signori
capore no questa non è di qua quindi
questa chiave deve trovare un'altra
porta piano piano si risolve anche il
mistero con quelle scene all'inizio
spiega anche che cosa sta succedendo il
piano piano forse riuscirà marzo al 20
mi manca la chiave verde proprio provate
hai sentito
che chiama vertice la chiave parte e
aspetta il martello vi serviva per
aprire quella porta falsamente sta
aprendo il martello eccetera una porta
chiusa fossero questa
[Musica]
parte
mi serve comunque
a prendere una chiave quella
tessera
[Applauso]
[Musica]
omerta
nel frattempo che aspettiamo che inizia
un'altra partita ecco centopiedi vi
ricordo che potete
preordinare il mio libro
mauro se non avete visto il video non ci
andate a vederlo dopo di questo perché
vi raccontiamo un po di cosa parla
poi l'arresto di nuovo libro sari
paurose tante storie super interessanti
di misteri invece un mistero da svelare
potete anche accumulare dei ponti
insomma è super divertente ma solo per i
primi ordini ci sarà la cartolina
firmata e autografata da me è quindi se
non l'avete ancora preordinato cliccato
il link descrizione preordinate do amor
prossimo partito acqua possiamo
scegliere se ci sono 12 100p e proviamo
con 200 piedi anche se sarà molto più
difficile
però vediamo noi 100 birre di vendiamo
siamo in quattro ecco che inizia la
storia e stiamo dormendo
dietro 100 piedi lo vedi
ora stiamo ai 100 piedi
ci stiamo muovendo sul di varmo staremo
per staccare qualcuno baiata capitale mi
attaccavo meno
povero vitale quindi vuol dire che sarai
tu un'ora dopo dice non basta evitare
nei 100 piedi bene vedere le isole di
dati delle impronte che vanno sul muro
vivo in centro
o prezzo scappiamo nello scantinato
ma noi siamo in tutto siamo in 4 300
piedi ora siamo in 200 piedi
pazienti non ce la faremo mai cerchiamo
le chiavi che non si crea un filtrante a
guai a te se mi mangi e
ti azzardare altrimenti quando sarò io
sento piedi distribuito solo te ne
stai divertendo dal centro unitissimo al
monte dove sarà dove il lucchetto blog
dove lo chiedono tutti lasciate un mi
piace per portarmi fortuna e non farmi
mangiare dal sito piene di rosa
considerata un occhietto blu libertà no
no niente tempo blu ma non volevo dire
aperte
a
chi ti sei rimasta da sola non credo che
da notare malta da signori ci starà
qualcun altro ci sei solo tu adesso e
allora perché ho visto questa persona
passare davvero io proposte per questo
giocatore forse sa giocare meglio di me
ah si mi ha condotto la porta giusta
grazie era per caso la porta blu nata la
dica che
fra compagni
dove sta la vita
mi sono incastrate
dei gas tra pro perché se vogliamo
vedere questa scena che brutta micale
detto piedi ottimo il camminamento sui
muri
sono queste castrucci forniti chiude la
porta che ti rimane chiuso lo ha detto
zio
allora spetta
sistema prima le porte sono ministro
giocatore allora dove sarà anita la
vediamo 8 aiuto può venire l'anti a
questo gioco ma soprattutto al 100 piedi
e protetti ma
vediamo la forma qui c'è una giocatrice
è
o no un altro giocatore è stato
eliminato sono rimasto da solo non so
neanche dove può andarne 11 o mi sono
allungato se non certo chiede
lunghissimo per ogni volta più di
qualcuno o di 20 con 100 pd più grave
affini
66 brutto tanto si lascia l'altro se tu
piedi da allora salta pure bene
classifica porto che cos'è quella cosa
ti sei non ti trovo più
allora io possa salire i muri
si sente muri basta
200 300 piani
mio brutto
brutto come si fa ad uscire di qui
aspettati vento a mangiare io davanti
saranno di casa pro vissuta non ce la
farò mai a capire cosa devo fare è
difficilissimo guidare a questo 100
piedi
di grendi questo 100 piedi non
dovendo che però non siamo sostenuti
dietro di me per noi perché scappi a
scappare detto se avuto se due qui
sembra di giocare a nascondino
prego ti prego
me la pagherai vita andrà via beta spera
di diventare il 100 piedi ha detto bran
arti ora votiamo per un socio viene
perché però in parte vediamo chi sarà il
100 piedi o con dies domini pervenute e
quello che passa la dietro ore assegnerà
la sua vittima da trasformare in 100
piedi gigawatt questa volta anita nostra
puntando ritor no io sono da un'altra
parte ha preso per la ragazza li a
quello di prima e ma come dorme quello
del giu
[Musica]
ok morti per la prossima partita allora
dobbiamo cercare di collaborare ok
collaboriamo cerchiamo le chiavi e
cerchiamo tutti gli oggetti che ci
servono successo a volte dobbiamo
riuscire a sconfiggere quella schifosa
100 piedi ok ho trovato una chiave blu
la chiave blues prendi ha preso la
chiave bene che mi ricordo come le
ultimi morti
una di queste porte non questa facevo il
martello lui ha la chiave rossa vediamo
se trovo è chiaro il martin era
a fumare allora questa è quella verde
questa ci vuole il martello che quello
che è l'es quale chiederò stampa chiave
rossa ce l'ha lui ok qua c'è la chiave
verde e chiave verde non ce l'ho ok lo
prenda lei mi presento mi chiamo rai
molto presto andiamo aprire la prima
rete si era qui la chiave blues e non
sbaglio poi apre la porta
e adesso che dobbiamo però non c'era
niente si dobbiamo prendere questo tipo
però non mi ricordo un vestito non lo so
troppo da vicino invece capire che senso
ha preso
provino
ma non è giusto io seguo lei sicuramente
però meglio di me dove andare o coperto
ok allora stimento spettatore io va il
tifo per noi certo allora ripartendo
dobbiamo trovare tiri porti dove lui c'è
dietro d'età non ho se non abbiamo
sentito il proprio per niente ecco la
porta verde
e quale fortunatamente il mondo
dove
forse vuole che la guidi io ma non mi
ricordo bene a dovere all'acqua
o no sento dei rumori
dove sono finiti gli altri giocatori
io sono stato eliminato ma era qua la
portò verduchi no a stato eliminato li
siete rimane vivo ai 100 piedi diventato
ancora più grande ora gigante ha paura
dove sono finiti gli altri a un altro
giocatore e con la porta verde noi non
piace però in una chiave come facciamo
detto che è stata mangiata quelle
colleghiamo al verde o no era quella
cosa è questa un passo giusto e grecia
non è
ma io ho deciso di
aiutare in questa mappa è un labirinto è
impossibile da capire adesso è
nuovamente la porta vero adesso ho preso
la chiamerò
ecco il momento che vivete o che posso
finalmente andare io ad aprire anche se
non mi ricordo dove stavo per dire tu
che sarete nella porta l'occhietto verde
roma
dovrebbe essere poco più avanti
mi sa che sei rimasto solo tu e non ho
mai mai mai che non deve curare il
problema
non posso nascondermi adesso non sento
piedi e li credo che sia rimasta da sola
non ha gioco
no forse ti conviene scappare senza
farmi vedere dal 100 piedi sì ci riesce
a è che brutto
si esce sicuramente
d'aiuto
forse da qui
[Musica]
prima secondo ma
eccoci di nuovo con l'asta ma questa
volta spero di essere io il 100 piedi
per sbranare vitale viviamo a scegliere
tromello altro non sono io ha detto
piedi e quell'altro al prossimo però io
anch'io sono un certo punto fa anche tu
ma come è possibile evitare già due
volte 100 piedi ora non ti dirò niente
fatti non mi insegue mi
aspetto lo stesso senso piedi e se anche
un altro sento piedi siamo amici abbiamo
note soppresso beh almeno non sono stato
io
avete visto sono io nel soffitto davvero
sono un certo
quando camminare nel soffitto
che belle cose in modo che non sappiate
questo mi fa stare bene guarda qua
per favore lasciamo in pace vitale dove
sei fatti
era per furto catturato in un apparente
ei bus bene mio core mio primo brutto la
manita e cattivissima e mi sono stata in
due adesso come ma che cos'è questa è
una persona non è una persona persona
che elimini come centopiedi diventi poi
più grande l'importante è trovare vitale
ma questo era nascosto quarto bra
non sa che io posso anche arrampicarvi
wow sono un 100 piedi ancora male al
piede malefico a 300 piedi 300 piedi
ho fatto per evitare cerchiamo vitale
subito dobbiamo prendere evitare per me
l'avessero sarà compiuta da veti di
accesso vedo qualcosa di blu eccolo ecco
minore brignano
dove credi di scappare non vuoi capire a
100 piedi 300 piedi
devo dire che scappi io vedevo aiuto
scappa scappa addobbi del k1 porta no no
no è difficilissimo usare questo 100
piedi dove è finito dove sei dai non
voglio farti niente da preoccuparsi
ti ho visto che non vivere o niente
ci sono due persone che siete pronti
entro i prezzi
siete no ho preso una persona ha
mangiato allora 2 bene sono ancora più
grande e adesso con o non dovete te non
mi ricordo dove compare ei notai e
lasciami in pace chi era questo como mia
che paura c'era uno con delle ali
giganti e delle ali se un 100 piedi con
delle hanno certo piedi un personaggio
però sapevo delle ali dove vitale devo
prendere vita nascosta siamo amore c'è
qualcuno qua vicino qualcuno ha aperto
la porta
vediamo se sono qua
[Musica]
dove siete non parlava
no
questo con le ali giganti dovrebbe moto
molto toccato
al culetto per un sento piedi e
diletta cerchiamo la chiave viola
aiutatemi a trovare la chiave viola
start di prendere abrevaya inutile che
sempre chi trovato uno
che se ci sono io che sta distruggendo
un po di cose
trovare bidoni to be no non trovo
nessuno sono una schiappa d'argento
piedi hai detto forte hai detto forlì
ben detto volevo dire c'è qualcuno c'è
qualcuno che prendiamo ancora ehi di
scappare ti ho appena visto dove sei
scappando no sta scadendo il tempo io
non sono così riprendere schiaffo fatto
può non ci credo che cosa abbiamo fatto
l'unica volta che io gioco da 100 piedi
riuscita a vincere poi
per fortuna preso un'altra però è
riuscito a scappare
com'è possibile
ci serve vi ricordo e abbiamo dovuto
prenderlo la chiave viola devo trovare
la chiave è bassissimo non riesco a
prenderlo di un sito
presto andiamo cimitan è
troppo bello perché noi sappiamo sempre
da te sì o no no no ma prenderlo devo
prenderla scappa scappa da anita
non posso venire a casa partito ad aver
falsato vitale dove sei
aiuterà che scappi tanti silenzi un
concerto ma io sono lentissima appunto
stato finito o no è riuscito a rijeka
allarme lo trovo più ho trovato la
chiave viola non ci credo 8 per finito
io ci credo al trovato la chiave viola
ho trovato ricambio ma ci avevano
portato qualcuno
no vabbè
c'è doveva per forza che abitare una
schiappa come idea che se comprendiamo
gioco
sarà mica che fate vincendo ma come
chiamo io la copertura costanza si creda
o no serve il martello per tentare la
chiave magnetica dove hanno rilasciato
il martello designers vediamo
cerchiamo il martello che ritroveremo
anche vitale ma io so dove l'ho lasciato
il martello finge sta andando a
prenderlo mamma mia mi sono spaventato
pensavo fosse allora il martello
[Musica]
che c'è fra
sbaglio ho visto una maglietta blu dove
sei ti devo mangiare cioè calcola che
sto per finire il gioco no non ci credo
non ci credo vitale che finisce il gioco
non so più dove cercarli e che cos'è
questo rumor qualcuno sta facendo
qualcosa fa no non mi dire sto provando
proprio
no è riuscito a ogni minuto non è
riuscito a prendere la chiave quello lì
mannaggia dove si è devo prenderlo no
tantissimi questo con le ali banda
faccia ci serve quella chiave
vero preso ragionò un minuto ma con
minuto forse solo possiamo fare che devo
prendere quest'altro con le ali g cabrio
entrato scappo forse riuscirò a vincere
come 100 piedi no mancano pochi secondi
ormai
quindi è rimasto solo vitale boh non lo
so io sono un 100 pd gigante sa però
dove vitale troppo fretta e vitale
non siamo forse comprendere vitale ma tu
sei uno sconto
invitiamo dove vitale novo che lo
pochissimi secondi non posso venire
gioco che sto per preso vita re forse
sto riuscendo a scappare forse 15
secondi 4 3 2 1
no
ma non mi dire che in tutù però no
perché non ti ho preso a kindle e virtù
sacco di punti 2 comunque però non si è
riuscito a prenderlo
super divertente vi ricordo di
preordinare storia paura se trova non
per ricevere la cartolina autografata
nome è vitale
allora mi lasciavo quattro case legno se
puoi cliccare per veder i nostri altri
video accanto a seconda che preferite
buona visione ciao